um hi everybody thanks for the
opportunity thank you to the organizers
and the sponsors so we take a small
break this a small shift and move the
standard bit is that okay stop all right
we're going to move away from the
hippocampus to look at the work that
we've been doing in the olfactory cortex
let's see it's also an alle cortical
area I like to think of it somewhat like
the hippocampus stuck on the outside of
the brain so the the goal of sensory
systems is not merely to detect stimuli
live in the environment but rather to
extract the relevant salient features of
those stimuli and represent them in a
way that's adaptive and meaningful in
order to drive in in this case or driven
behaviors so if we think of the the
challenges that this dog needs to
overcome in order to follow us enters to
its source one gets a sense of some of
the complexity involved so for example
she needs to be exquisitely scent
sensitive to a particular odor and be
able to discriminate between two odors
it may be very similar right at the same
time she needs to be able to generalize
for the targa DOTA and for example
identify that odor over variable
conditions such as in increase in Odin
concentration and so my lab is
interested in trying to understand how
these computations are affected in in
the brain so odors are first detected
when odor of molecules bind to olfactory
sensory neurons in the nasal epithelium
each sensory neuron expresses just one
out of a thousand different types of
bowden receptor genes and all sensory
neurons expressing a given gene
converging this unique pair of
structures and the olfactory bulb in the
first stage of odor processing in the
brain called lamellae right so here you
can see a series of neurons in all
expressing this one receptor the p2
receptor and the axons of these neurons
all converging the structure over there
the output cells of the olfactory bulb
of the mitral and tufted cells and these
cells extend a single apical dendrite
into just one to marry us and project
this information to downstream cortical
olfactory errors so the the the flow of
voter information from the receptor
through the sensory neuron to the
Camaro's and into the cortex is
essentially a labeled line that is
specific for the particular molecular
features of the aura consequently if one
were to image the activity of the mitral
cell and that's what some bozo has done
here one can see that different odors
will activate particular combinations of
glomeruli or mitral cells that represent
that the molecular features of that
information the sort of elemental
combination of elements needs to be
combined downstream of the olfactory
bulb to form a synthetic representation
of a right and so that happens in the
olfactory cortical areas the largest of
which is the powerful with the primary
olfactory cortex of the parent cortex so
if one were to image activity of a
population of neurons and peripheral
cortex is really in control my main
collaborator Alex Fleischman has done
one can see that here each of these dots
represents an identified neuron in an
anesthetized Mouse and the the color
code indicates neurons are responsible
to one of these four particular one of
these three odors and cells that are
shown in white are responsive to
multiple different odors and so we can
see that a given odor will activate this
distributor ensembles and neurons and
peripheral cortex and it could be said
that that that particular ensemble in
fact we we and Alex have shown that the
the ensemble of neurons is sufficient to
accurately represent the identity of the
other not for the purposes of my talk it
will be very useful to understand a
little bit about the structure of
paraffin cortex as I mentioned it's in
our cortex it's a three layer cortex
that contains essentially a single layer
of principal neurons or pyramidal cells
that are located in layer two these
cells extend apical dendrites up towards
the peel surface where they receive
excitatory synaptic
actions from combinations of olfactory
people mitral cells the the projection
from bulb to cortex is shows no
topographic organization some people
have said it's random as far as we can
tell there's no evidence that it's not
that allows individual neurons within
piriform cortex to respond to possibly
unique combinations back tomorrow in
addition to their excitatory connections
onto the pyramidal cells these cells
also make exciting connect the micro
cells also make excitatory connections
onto a layer of inhibitory onto a class
of inhibitory neurons located in layer
one that provide feed-forward inhibition
on to the traveler cells now much like
ca3 peripheral cortex is a densely
interconnected recurrent structure in
which excitatory accents from these
parameters project across the extent of
her from cortex this has the structure
of an order associative Network similar
to the types of things that we heard
about from from Jim and and of this is
why and these recurrent the this
recurrent circuitry is thought to be
very important for things like patent
completion and amplification of specific
types of receptors
I'll give the punch like the punch line
away right now in case anybody needs to
leave I'm going to make the argument
that that is only one and perhaps a
small role of this extensive recurrent
circuitry because in addition to forming
excited connections on two pyramidal
cells they also form very strong
connections on two separate class of
inter neurons located in layer three
that provide very strong feedback
inhibition
into the pyramidal on two back onto the
pyramidal cells so let's return to the
baldwin consider the following problem I
mentioned that a given Oda wadda at a
specific combination of chimera lie and
one could presumably in some sort of
cartoon model decode the the identity of
the other from the specific combination
of activated to marry lie alright but
what happens if we change the
concentration of the odor we know
perceptually that the quality of the
identity event of an odor is robust to
large changes in concentration however
a particular subset of activated
glomeruli this is quite steep you
concentration-dependent this makes sense
right because these receptors are
activated by mass action kinetics so as
you increase the concentration of the
Odori so you will increase the
activation of the merit of receptors and
consequently here you can see for
example for one odor over a range of one
order of magnitude concentration there's
a drastic increase in the number of
activated tumor a lot it's also like if
you turn off as yeah actually they sorry
that they don't what one of the tricks
that they did here is normalize
everything to leave at the highest point
so some glimmer like become more
responsive at higher concentrations but
in fact that's that's correct right so
how do we solve this problem and I think
Laurent says pointing to the fact that
they may be fairly complicated solutions
to this but one apps relatively simple
an elegant solution was proposed
initially by john hopfield and he
suggested the model is essentially this
consider we have three an odor odor a
that activates three Demara light
indicated by the blue green and magenta
circles and there and their constituent
mitral cells and it activates this odor
a activates these three blue merrily
with a specific set of affinities such
that the blue blue meredith of mitral
cells are most sensitive to that odor
and the magenta ones are least sensitive
to that odor
consider another related odor or a bee
that activates the same subset of camara
light but with the reverse set of
affinities hop fields insight was that
one might be able to separate these
representations using time and time
related to the respiration cycle so for
example
rodents or mammals breathe and over the
they have we have these respiration
cycles that are typically on the order
of a theta cycle 300 or so milliseconds
long and so the insight that hopper had
was the following the the most sensitive
neurons the most sensitive Gamera the
most sensitive micro cells actually
would be the ones that are activated
earliest after inhalation so in the case
of odor a the micro cells associated
with this blue glue meredith's would
fire before those associated with the
green or the magenta glue marry light
whereas in four order B even though the
same set of mitral cells are activated
in this case the magenta ones would fire
earlier than the blue ones and so if
there was some way of sort of amplifying
the impact of the early inputs one could
sort of avoid the spurious recognitions
using hopfield terminology associated
with the activation of these lower
affinity maryland particular at higher
pressure made known a transition from a
rate code to a time SS corrected so the
silent transition because your images
they were not a phase log or anything
they were just raised yeah we're going
to move very quickly I will not I will
not show another image for exactly that
reason
the same model can be used for trying to
generalize for concentration so imagine
now we just have order a and either a
lower or high concentration whoops
excuse me at low concentration the only
the high affinity glomeruli and mitral
cells might be activated perhaps with
some weak activation of this moderate
affinity glomerulus at higher activity
at higher concentrations all three of
these Gamera line will be activated but
you'll always activate the most
sensitive
lemare line microsomes before you
activate that the less sensitive ones
right I'm just objecting to the just
from where you are in your story to the
buried spurious as if it's as if it's
spurious information but it clearly is
part of the code of B odor which of the
plumeria law activated in which order
and so I'm just kind of curious why why
you're why you're inclined to throw out
the later activated glomeruli as if they
don't carry information that is a
contentious I'm gonna answer this in a
few different ways one that's a
contentious statement and I don't
necessarily agree with it to hopfield
use the words spurious and I'm jumping
over three I would love to have this
conversation but it's going to take a
while so we can return to that maybe in
the discussion all right so if one can
use the same sort of temporal filtering
strategy where one selectively responds
to the earliest inputs and sort of
ignores the stuff that comes later then
you can sort of solve this problem of
concentration invariants right and a key
prediction sorry and I should I should
mention that there's no considerable
evidence that odors are encoded using
this type of temporal structure in the
olfactory bulb what's not known and what
is key for this model is that the
downstream decoder ie the peripheral
cortex should be selectively responsible
to the earliest inputs that are coming
from the bulb and should try and avoid
let me use it again these spurious
impacts are coming later right so we
wanted to ask whether or not that that's
the case this is the first time I've
that should just run in the background
so to do that we developed a method
particularly because these images are
static in which we can record from
populations of neurons in awake behaving
animals and to do this we use 32 channel
neuro nexus probes that we lower either
into the of the the mitral cell layer
and the olfactory bulb or here into
layer to appear from cortex and alright
our electrode spans the spans layer 2 we
can typically record from on the order
of 100 neurons of the team asleep so
here what I'm showing you is that race
in real-time
we're on the top we're measuring
measuring the respiration of the animal
with a flow meter place outside the nose
and on the bottom of the roster plots
from 40 simultaneously reported neurons
we trigger odor on on exhalation which
is indicated here in gray and measure
the spikes within the first sniff after
starting with both inhalation
some people have shown now a number of
groups have shown that animals can
reliably discriminate others in the
within a single sniff and then we
therefore realize that all the
information that we need should be
encoded within that step and so for the
stroke today I'm going to ask three
simple questions and then ask how is
odor information transformed from bulbs
of cortex and in our sport of the
circuit mechanisms that implement this
transformation and I'm going to ask for
all the computational consequences or
the computational roles that each of
these circuit mechanisms play ok so
here's an example of one experiment here
was recording simultaneously from
Microsoft in the fall
I've heard from neurons in the in the
cortex and here our roster plots from 20
my trousseau unit since 68 appear from
yarns the red line indicates at the
beginning of inhalation and what I've
done is sought these neurons by their by
their onset what you can see sorry so
this is a single trial this is the
average over a number of firing rates
and what you can see is that what we
find which is in agreement with what
others find is that individual micro
cells respond throughout the sniff and
there aren't it latency style basically
the extent
by contrast what we see in the pair from
cortex is there's something quite quite
quite different there's a robust
responds that respond early in the sniff
and there's very little activity that
happens later on we can see that more
clearly here now I've presented a single
odor at multiple concentrations here a
representative single neuron a single
neuron in either the quarter the bulb of
the cortex in response to three
different concentrations of hexanol and
what I'm showing you here you'll see a
lot of these traces over the course of
this talk are population responses in
which we record from individual units we
calculate para stimulus time histograms
for each unit and then we come but we
basically throw away all the single unit
information and combine these to format
a population firing rate and so what you
can see is that at the beginning of the
sniff there's a robust response in both
the bulb and the cortex but then later
on there's this large envelope of
activity which is actually quite
concentration dependent in the bulb
that's just simply not represented in
the quarters it's like the cortex is
sort of actively ignoring this this
stuff that's that's coming in later
again remember these micro cells are the
direct after an inputs to performance we
use an octogenarian sperm ation a little
more directly in this case we used a
mouse i Nath I won channelrhodopsin mice
a line that expresses channelrhodopsin
in micro cells and recorded now just
proof of principle from its single
neuron on the dorsal surface and we give
single we give one second long light
pulses of different intensities and what
you can see is that there's this great
and sustained activation of Microsoft's
when we up to genetically
activate evolve so now what we do is
report simultaneously from this mice
recording on the ventral surface of the
bulb so we're getting a lower bound
estimate of the total output of the bulb
as well as impaired from cortex and we
give these one second on light pulses of
different intensities and what we find
lowest intensity is that there's a small
increase in small and sustained increase
in firing in the bulb that's just not
represented
so perhaps we just weren't stimulating
strongly enough so we turned the similar
twister we turn the laser on a little
bit we turned the laser power up a
little bit and now what we see is again
sort of there's a peak with the sustain
phase in the cortex in the bulb that's
just not represented there's this
transient response and bulb in the
cortex and as we turn the laser strength
up more and more and more we see the
same thing this rapid onset in cortex
that's immediately suppressed - or in
fact even below baseline firing and then
that recovers quickly after the light
goes off so this indicates that the
piriform is actively suppressing its
responses to the later bulb input what's
the source of this suppression I
mentioned that there are these
feed-forward into neurons that receive
input from the mitral cells and these
may be these seem to be well poised to
shut off all but the earliest inputs on
the other hand we have fairly we think
based on some slice work that I and
others have done that in fact it's this
recurrent circuitry driving this
feedback recurrent inhibition that seems
to be that that is poised or is that may
have a much more pronounced input on
impact sorry on the cortical response so
to address this we again use enough to
genetic approach this time using a vga
channelrhodopsin mouse in which we
express channelrhodopsin in all
inhibitory interneurons and we take
advantage of the lamina segregation of
the feed-forward into neurons in layer 1
and the feedback into neurons in layer 2
to be able to target where which neurons
were reporting from so we lower our
probes that it spans layer 2 and if we
turn the light on because we're
activating inter neurons we can reliably
activate neurons in either layer 3 or
layer 1 while suppressing the vast
majority of we get negative pyramidal
cells in layer 2 and we can then look at
the older responses in these different
possible
and what we find is that when we look at
layer 1 we see that they have a fairly
high firing rate which corresponds to
the reasonably high firing rate of the
micro cells and so their tonically
active without a dramatic admirable
response this suggests to us that these
that this feed-forward inhibition is
probably playing a role as some sort of
high-pass filter for our factory bulb
input but is not playing a pronounced
role in shaping the corporate response
by contrast if we look at the response
of these feedback in inhibitory neurons
we see that their activity is predicted
by this brief increase in activity in
the in the pyramidal cells and their
activity in turn predicts the pronounced
suppression that we see in the parameter
source of the course of the sniff
indicating that they are likely
responsible for shutting or that they
are responsible for shutting off the
cortical response now because these
feedback inhibition neurons don't
receive input from the mitral cells but
do but are driven instead by the
pyramidal cells within the cortex this
indicates that the cortex itself is
deciding what information is represented
and what information is suppressed and
that points to a role for this recurrent
collateral network in essentially
implementing some this temporal filter
so we wanted to test that and to do that
we use the following strategy in which
we can mute these pyramidal cells we use
an EMF scream ow that expresses Craver
combination pyramidal cells and inject
it over the unilaterally injected over
the extent of her from cortex in a AV
that selectively expresses tetanus toxin
increase crossing neurons
this allows these this will essentially
block output from these parameter cells
while allowing them to spike and leaving
the rest of this circuit intact in it
we've done a number of extensive
controls in vitro to show that this is
the case in the interest of time today I
want to talk about this today what we
did now is record
bilaterally from this unilaterally
injected mice and first experiment I'll
show you is what happens when we cross
one of these mice with one of the 5-1
mice we can see that when we activate
the bulb when we activate the bulb we
now see this this large and sustained
increase in firing on both hemispheres
however when we look in the in the
piriform what we see in the control side
is over for this rapid transient input
followed by a vise the sustain
suppression whereas none of the when we
get rid of recurrent excitation we now
see the step functions transfer
transferred to the cortex is represented
in the quarters what happens when we
look at odor this is the population
response from the contralateral side you
can see again this very brief blip
followed by a pronounced suppression I
want to point out that an individual
neuron receives on the order of ten
times more recurrent inputs than it does
after it inputs and so was some what was
remarkable to us that when we got rid of
the recurrent excitation the vast
majority of the excitatory input onto
these cells instead of seeing some
instead of seeing a role for this
recurrent Network in amplifying the
response which is one what one might
expect we saw that receive that the
responses were in fact much much larger
when recurrent inhibition was relieved
we also looked at the responses to
different odorants and here and just
showing total population firing rate as
a function of auto concentration and
what we saw before is that in under
normal conditions this rule there's a
robust normalization of cortical output
across odor on concentrations and now
what we see is that the cortex becomes
very steeply concentration dependent
finally we looked at au decoding what
I'm showing you here is the accuracy of
a simple linear classifier as a function
of number of cells in two responses
under three different conditions
responses to six different odorants at a
given nominal continent concentration
sorry decoding responses to single to
six different odorants at a nominal
concentration decoding responses to a
single odorant at multiple
concentrations or generalizing for
odorant identity across a range of
concentrate
effectively asking the decoder to
identify a familiar order novel
concentration what we can see is that in
the control cases that we decode it as
relatively well however in the tetanus
case we see effects that are rather
interesting there's a small decrease in
the ability to classify the different
odorants which would be sort of
consistent with the idea that this
recurrence circuitry helps with pattern
separation or D correlation of these
overlapping inputs there's no real
effect on concentration decoding which
makes sense given that these recurrent
circuits are helping to normalize the
response but there's a pronounced loss
in the ability to generalize for odor
and identity across concentration so
what do we think is happening here under
normal conditions this is this is what I
showed you earlier let's imagine the
again these two odors or a in order be
that of overlapping inputs what happens
effectively in the cortex is that what
you're representing or the the earliest
inference and this allows you to
decorrelated these inputs or in the case
of different concentrations by
responding selectively to the earliest
input oh I messed that up that should be
blue on the bottom sorry I made this
last night what what happens here is
that you're just representing the with
the same motor that's a bit of a slip
all right and so let me quickly
summarize and sorry and when we when we
eliminate the recurrent circuitry and we
basically are now driving the cortex
just by bulb input what happens is that
these these correlated inputs result
instead of confusing patterns in the
cortex and this concentration and and
and the ability to sort of form a
concentration invariant representation
of the other identities
we summarize by saying that the earliest
bulb input seemed to primarily define
the cortical order representation that
this is implemented by some sort of sort
of when it take all the temporal
winner-take-all filtering that's
implemented by this long-range recurrent
circuitry driving strong feedback
inhibition and this supports
concentration invariant odor recognition
quarters and with that I will thank you
for attention I'd also like to thank the
people who did the work most of this
work has been done by a postdoc in my
lab kevin bolding work that I haven't
spoken about for my collaborators and my
[Applause]
wake they're awake behave now we've only
tried modern what do you mean familiar
novel odors no I in some cases were
reported multiple times from a given
animal typically no more than two or
three recordings per animal and we're
using sort of standard monomolecular
Sigma odorants so there's there's no
prior experience with these no not yet
could you clarify what you mean by
concentration in very encoding way does
it seems like you can beat out both the
identity and the concentration from the
code right yes so it is what you're
saying closer to saying that you encode
both but that you're encoding both yeah
so we published a paper earlier I guess
what not this year last year in e-life
where we sort of go into this and in
quite a lot of detail and I'd encourage
you to look at that but basically what
we find is sort of complementary almost
multiplex coding schemes for identity
and intensity so oder identity is
encoded by the specific combination of
glob activated neurons and peripheral
cortex over the course of a sniff and
the and the intensity or the
concentration seems to be encoded using
some sort of temporal coding strategy
structure in which the in which
intensity is encoded by the synchrony of
the ensemble so what I'm talking about
here by concentration invariant coding
is the ability to generalize for
identity over a range of concentrations
so I'm talking about I should say
concentration invariant odor recognition
Kevin I brought this up earlier you know
we're talking about what you lose when
you chop off the later activities where
yeah it seems like you're saying kind of
to a first approximation the first
glomerulus that's active becomes the
code because the later ones
the first primarily that are active
right but I'm just wondering about that
because if it was literally that the
first input then they're after the first
activated glomerulus is active it sort
of shuts off of the cortex after that
yeah different odors that you could
recognize because there's a lathe oh
yeah no but what I'm saying is that the
first input doesn't need to be one it
could be four or five or seven out of a
thousand okay okay and I think
evolutionarily this makes sense
you you have a large number of molecules
in the environment that you need to be
able to detect so this and be able to
detect very low concentrations so one
solution that one might use to solve
this problem is you create an array of a
thousand different detectors that are
all exquisitely sensitive to different
features and sort of the cost of doing
business is that those those detectors
those receptors that are exquisitely
sensitive to a small subset of the
possible number of voters that exist are
going to also respond at high
concentration of other inputs right the
way to select for the ones that are sort
of most optimally tuned for this
particular order would be to look at the
ones that are strongly activated at the
very very beginning
so I was wondering how this generalizes
to multiple Hooters or to what extent
many was actually able to yeah mixture
absolutely so this periodic we've done
mixtures we we've have but not very well
my old my my supervisors lab my
supervisor has done this my previous
supervisor has done this and what they
found is pronounced mixture sir pressure
and there's not a lot of quantification
in that but basically what they saw this
is a paper from Staedtler and axle in
2009 is that a given odor odor a will
activate on the order of 10% of the
neurons empirical for this order B will
activate approximately 10% of the
neurons empirical quarters and order a
plus B together will activate
approximately 10% of the neurons
empirical cortex with that mixed
combination is largely a subset of some
of the neurons that were activated by
order a and some of the neurons that
were activated by order P with a few new
ones and many of the ones who are
activated by either A or B dropping out
they have no idea what underlies that
mixture suppression I think that our
model solves us but we don't have data
for that yet
I think it solves it in the following
way I'm not against of speaking to
Bartlett's question I'm not suggesting
that it's the first girl Mary Alice it
defines the the old response there are a
thousand different lemare aligned we can
tile the sniff with with all thousand
let's imagine it's more sparse let's
imagine we tell the snip with all ten
with a hundred right and let's let's
suppose that the first 10 are the ones
that define the old response so you'll
have a rank order latency order of the
of the of each of the activated might
results for order a and odor B and
basically if you combine these and what
you could imagine is that the response
to the mixture of those most strongly
activated by a and B right we haven't
done that I think that's what's going on
and I think that so I think what happens
with the mixtures you get this sort of
the most robust elements of that mixture
for this overlay superposition sort of
we see that these are two different
folders like and hyper dimensional
computing or something unless unless
what unless the percept that emerges
when you put these MOU these mixtures
together changes I suspect they are this
is a mixture mixed off strawberry or
something yeah so there's been some
psychophysical work in humans with this
and it it's I think we can take with a
grain of salt h well the train perfumer
or assuming you can pick out mmm
notes in in you know in a perfume or a
while right an untrained person smelling
novel combinations of odors typically
has a lot of difficulty identifying the
elements in the mixture of more than
three or four at that point it basically
becomes a synthetic of Gestalt
representation of the mixture and the
individual components become
indistinguishable
so that that needs to be done more and
better but that that's what we do you
think there's an advantage to the system
doing this winner-take-all network tap
the cortex level it seems like you could
do it earlier and not bother with
transmitting all those exercises like as
well very wise in each other
so one advantage might be the following
the the pair I mentioned the pair from
cortex is the so this is speculation
right peripheral cortex is the largest
of the cortical factory areas but it's
not the exclusive target of the
olfactory about might result of the
olfactory bulb
it's the cortical structure where
associative order representations are
thought to be all right it's where we
think we form the identity of odors that
have no intrinsic or by it biologically
innate importance and so that seems like
it might be a good place in which to
implement this filter however there are
there are odor instead of biologically
or that are innately relevant so for
example in the case of a mouse that
would be fox urine right so you could
imagine a low concentration of fox your
sorry and and we think we being the
field that there's a mitral cells
projected a number of different cortical
targets lodged which is peripheral
cortex also projected cortical amygdala
the tubercle and lateral internal cortex
thought that the paraffin cortex is
where these associative representations
of odor or formed
whereas innately relevant odors seem to
projected to the amygdala and that might
be driving innate responses okay so in
that case you might not want to filter
the stuff upstream you might want to let
that get through and if you have low
concentrations of fox urinate over a
background of something that's very very
very high then if you implement the
temporal filter upstream you might lose
that
probably one yes
[Applause]